in 2005 when I did a show called the
eyes of Nye companies like Monsanto had
patents on genes and people were
questioning whether or not that was
ethical also there was this overarching
idea that we have enough food we just
can't distribute it properly and the
reason people are starving in the world
is there's enough food and my concern
was the ecosystem this is to say you can
know each organism very well and by no I
mean you can know its the sequence of
its genes and you can grow it in
isolation and refuges and see how it
performs and this time at crops now
there would be no need to experiment
with the ecosystem even though you can
know the individual crop plant you don't
know what it would do when it's around
butterflies or bees or birds or other
pollinators or some virus we haven't
discovered yet since then a couple
things three things have happened to my
way of thinking the the least
significant may be that we can now assay
genes 10 million this is to say no 100
million 10 to the 8th times faster than
we could 15 or 20 years ago the DNA
sequencing machines are so sophisticated
you can actually simulate what would
happen if this virus comes in or that
gene is introduced from a vector or an
insect vector or what have you that's
the first thing that you can make
predictions about how plants will grow
based on their genes very accurately
much more so you could a couple decades
ago the second thing is there are 7.3
billion people in the world right now
early in the twenty twenty first century
by the middle of the 21st century this
is going to be 9 billion there might
even be 10 billion people so those
people are going to have to be fed
and sure enough the way to do that is
almost certainly with genetically
modified crops which are much more
productive than they used to be and then
from a historic standpoint humans have
always hybridized crops but now
humans are hybridizing him from a
genetic standpoint not just by combining
sexually crops of desirable traits and
the third thing that's very compelling
to me as a scientist is we've discovered
and maybe everybody knew this except me
and I'm the first of them that we've
discovered that genes are introduced
between species naturally and the paper
that really got to me was the one about
sweet potatoes so sweet potatoes became
sweet potatoes because something like a
virus infected the sweet potatoes and
changed their genes and then humans
cultivated those gene changed potatoes
and so without this introduction of
inter species between species genetic
transfer this wouldn't have happened so
this these three things the ecosystem
concerned the rate at which we can assay
genes the number of people that are
gonna have to be fed that's the second
one and the third one is it happens
naturally anyway these three things have
changed my point of view about
genetically modified foods and the
regulations for them are actually quite
robust you can't just go creating a crop
plant that's going to be deleterious to
the farming system along with this
everybody first to admit the idea that
you can that you can patent genes seems
troubling but there's a little bit so
there's a lot to it that's very
reasonable
companies like pioneer the seed company
this part of DuPont and the B mixed
feelings Monsanto they spend a lot of
money a huge fraction of their resources
on developing these plants and
recently the patented soybean expired a
patent expired so soybeans are out now
so okay so if you want to grow those
soybeans now you can and farmers do make
contracts to grow those plants because
they grow better so what we can imagine
a future where plants are tuned to grow
in very moist soils at the bottom of the
hill where the water runs down very dry
soils at the top of the hill where the
water drains away quickly and in between
and the plants that would be planted the
crop plants that would be planted would
very like meet her to meet her certainly
it will cross across the farm field they
would vary from one end to the other and
they would be planted electronically
using global positioning from outer
space and this will enable people to
feed the world so I used to be against
genetically modified foods just for from
the cautionary principle you don't know
what you're doing the ecosystem so be
careful now I am for genetically
modified foods because we have so much
more science behind that than we did
even 20 years ago